if a one piece is in space ever since an
L flew up to the Moon fans have been
speculating that the one piece might be
in space but my favorite theory is that
the one piece is actually on a comet
that only appears once every 800 years
in the real world there are comets that
only appear once every several centuries
so that checks out and the last time
this particular comment appeared may
have been during the void Century Joy
boy and the ancient Kingdom lost the
ancient war but they knew that the one
piece was too important to give up to
their enemies so they hit it on a comet
knowing that it would be saved for at
least another 800 years by the time the
Comet came back Joy boy would also
return in the form of Luffy and he could
finally retrieve it that is why Rogers
said that he was too early back then the
comet was still too far away subscribe
to anime uproar right now for more crazy
one-piece theories like